okay up hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to the rake
multiplayer beta but we say beta umm
this game hasn't been updated in almost
a year now the developer like gave up on
it but it's here and there's multiplayer
and I played this game a while before
and it scared me not from the monster
but from everything else that happened
to the game so let's do it
wait for shotgun or sniper rifle I'll
take Shogun there you go and there's
some [ __ ] there's some Phil chase right
rear - ok so I got the shells wait no
those rifle ammo crazy is that correct
there's more right there ok
look like it seems right seems good
enough for me ok so if you guys remember
the rake the rake is a game that's made
about the rake which is a creepypasta
about a creature that's out in the woods
long spindly arms it's like um it's like
a when to go from until dawn remember
yep like that like that be a fairly app
description now they're not the same
thing at least as far as I know but
they're pretty darn close so explain the
multiplayer beta with us please mr. Wade
so the multiplayer from what I've
gathered it's always night the day/night
cycle doesn't work the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
nevermind yeah we're fine everything's
fine uh and uh that's about it it's
always night there's different guns
there's ammo and there was one wasted
ammo sorry don't mind me well if I shoot
you nothing
Wow nothing to the bird but you're right
it's Dungy yeah what happened to Bessie
where's Bessie you don't talk about it
where's Bessie Bessie yo how do you
close this all right here I don't know I
don't think it works anymore there's a
lot of things what does that sound
probably nothing good probably nothing
no place this other camera before gets
to be too late all right so yeah it's
always night which means that we're just
kind of left out in the lurch in the
middle of the woods
and we have no idea what we're doing
right pretty much and those you know
where some things are so I can direct
you to some places be hey it's been a
while since I played this game like I
can't really remember much about the
environment all I know is that the guy
does he still scream want to get spooked
by the rake like the guy in the game I
think so yeah because like that's the
only thing that actually scared me in
the game besides the pigs that are
wandering around in the woods the bits
between the pigs and this guy are more
terrifying than the rake thankfully we
have these pathways to guide us ah good
good aids no now oh so there's some
useful bear traps up ahead that we will
gather okay I'm going for what happens
if I step on them uh nothing good
probably um okay I think what oh ha
straight up here okay sorry
wait for me hello ominous music oh hello
ominous music who's slightly delayed for
me but I I got it if you want to climb
up in here and get those bear traps all
go get the ones that are over to the
left you got it um on yeah I remember
late woops I remember like exploring the
entirety of the map and I couldn't
really find go back walking how good
poet my bad they weren't up there were
they oh you sack of [ __ ]
I actually believed you that didn't
happen before I actually believed you I
can't believe it I trusted you this
whole goddamn time you get back here you
[ __ ] you get off [ __ ] crap oh hey
look some bear traps I can't uh are you
we're [ __ ] alright fine I got the beer
trip the mouse like it goes outside of
the game that's fascinated - I can't
believe that still a thing yeah that I
clicked out a little while ago it I'm
Mia I'm in full screen mode okay I just
can't shoot if I shoot I gotta pull a
full left turn first and then shoot
that's what I'm gonna do yeah remember
if there's anything in any of those or
not really one has a job scare as far as
I do
uh-huh okay sure yeah whatever the other
ones do nothing nothing happen
let me trick you oh nothing okay
nicey-nice okay
everything's just safe and hunky-dory
and nothing's gonna eat our faces off
what is this an outhouse there a map I
don't remember if there's a map doesn't
look like em doesn't there's a map at
the beginning of the base in the van I
believe maybe we should go back and
figure out where to go next things I
don't know how to get to like the sniper
rifle we gotta go through a cave or
something oh yeah I remember the cave
but I don't remember how to get there
I'm totally disoriented because it's the
middle of the night obviously yeah it's
very late and I keep thinking I'm
hearing zombies because we just played
seven days to die not that long ago so
every noise in the night I'm thinking
we're being attacked yeah this is like
me and dead by daylight wait which one
to change off
is this the way we came I don't know not
by far I don't think oh yeah here's the
gate okay never mind I was completely
wrong you're right oh look at me I'm
wait I'm a big smarty smooth thank you
that's the nicest thing you've said not
sarcastically at all okay what about
behind the van is there anything behind
this you me yeah oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
was that what was that I don't know I'm
not over there anymore was something
scampering about in the woods that
sounded bad it wasn't as either the rake
or was a pig it was something ooh you
know like you that me know like you that
oh there's a ha crap whoa you're right
you okay
he beat me in the bones you okay you
dead I'm good just
pane which way did you go up the hill
Blake to the right hold to the right
like I leave his camera that you bow hey
hey okay what did you find there's a
house across the way and he popped out
of a tree and spanked me oh nice it's so
nice of him that he doesn't actually
kill you
well I said a camera she's okay good
what I can't clobber you you heard the
camera sound yeah it's not like my gr
dammit
that tree looked really scary ooh hello
your branch that wasn't me
did you place a camera no I wasn't
looking one oh geez
this might be where we want to go might
not be way it's gonna take us somewhere
oh I hear something what's that
ooh ah here we go ah hello it's a good
place to be all these always yeah I
don't know it I don't know it doesn't
sound good
Oh doesn't that's not good at all yeah
okay all right oh it's like right around
I'm gonna hug the left wall here okay
whoa uh where'd you go up right so
here's a boat yeah there's a foot I
found it this neighbor rival right here
go get it get it buddy yeah yours we did
it
did you find the foot oh there's a foot
look how big that leg is I saw honking
leg man like with you standing next to
it that's all yeah huge leg yeah meaty
I'm so raking reel that thing whoa no
yeah you know I've never actually
explored over here other than to get the
sniper rifle is there anything else over
here
sounds like there's water other than
that I have no idea oh my goodness there
was a plant that just had the wrong
shape looks like it maybe it's the house
I was looking for yeah could be looks
like there's a light on in there yeah oh
that's the waterfall I remember seeing
that because I spotted that in the
distance he was like what are you saw
virtual margin and then it was a war
anything out of waterfall I don't think
so but there's there's also beacons of
light do you see that oh it's water no
it's not little flowers there's a cave
under the waterfall who is there yeah
I'll join you in the cave I live hey not
bad
I hear it I hear that munching noise and
a what you think why I don't know was oh
hello what is this this is a grave that
you're gonna bury me in could you drag
me all the way over here I know what you
did with lower it okay no uh Rick come
on it's been years
we let this meme die you think we let it
you think you can resurrect it but you
can't you think I can't but I'm gonna
ask you let me try
Picaro for Gore Gore oh man coral if
nobody remembers that I don't blame you
man it wasn't worth remember and don't
be in here yeah yeah there's absolutely
dick yeah well I don't know what the
point of that was why have this entire
cave system but nothing in it no no no
it's really bizarre well why have a lot
of things in this game but nothing in it
very good questions
oh my go that looks like thorns I'm
gonna keep looking for our house there's
got to be that house around here yeah
what was in the house jump-scares I
think there was more ammo oh well we
don't really need it I mean have you
ever managed to actually kill the rake
yes okay by cheating it that's okay I'm
alright with cheating
trust me in fact the last time if I
remember right we had a dance party with
it nice
that's our grade it's very lovely hmm
is there anything on the map in the van
that shows where a house might be maybe
if we can find her I don't think we can
I think we're screwed why haven't I seen
any piggies I used to see lots and lots
of piggies when I was playing before
they are a bit rarer now well there's
something wait this the same waterfall
no way
no this is different it's got a bigger
leading up to it okay well that's weird
around anything in this one is it not
that thing behind it it looks like
shotgun ammo or sniper ammo okay
I can click shotgun it's not clickable
what's helpful there's been a shortage I
feel like of quality horror games and
there's not been a whole lot of
creepypasta related games in a while
that I've found so there hasn't been a
lot of new creepypasta in forever that's
true there's not there's nothing much
love given to the rake though this is
the only game I really know of about it
yeah the other rate games were just
terrible the heart monster to
incorporate at least this was an open
world attempt at it I guess yeah I mean
but this game being not developed isn't
quite like you know Petey being canceled
like yeah it's not that big of a loss
but it's still I heard I've not played
it I heard the new Resident Evil looks
pretty promising though
oh yeah it looks really good like I mean
obviously when I played the demo there
trying to be PT that's what they were
going for they were going for that hard
to figure out what the hell is going on
style and you know they were obviously
trying to mimic that but you know it
still had promise
the only bad thing I heard about it was
apparently they had some time-locked
stuff that angered people time-lock
yeah parently there was like a finger
there was some random objects you
couldn't use yeah they time-locked some
stuff that so you had to wait til they
unlocked it to use it oh that's stupid
I didn't even know about it unlocking
later I found another perch
oh I'm just back to camp okay good I
keep finding waterfalls I'm just gonna
keep running in the straight line see
where I end up man why do you keep
trying them wonderful cuz I'm probably
wandering around stupid probably uh what
was that it jumped out of a bush oh okay
you're right yeah hey man you're getting
all the skiers and not me
I yeah I led you to one scare now I'm
paying the price figured it's karma baby
is the house that we got the traps the
other side of that house he popped out
okay sure
Louise I deserve that but God I'm gonna
check the cameras that I placed on the
see cam one camera to you huh I see
nothing I see feels black oh god I see
you holy [ __ ]
I saw you creeping up on one of the
cameras that was you right yeah there's
another random hunter wait wait is it
you good the scariest creature is man
you better have a good reason for me
being out in these woods I haven't seen
no rake round here
oh holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you come
from I well I didn't know you could
close that well where's the god
damn rake I don't know he broke the
camera but he always loves to break this
camera up on this hill
alright well I'm gonna put a camera up
there and then I'm gonna wait we're
gonna wait for him and when he attacks
you because he doesn't like you
we're gonna get it I was gonna do that
alright where he at rap down I'm gonna
put bear trap down nope [ __ ] you hi ow
my face ow
get some footage of this what did you
watch that no I was like oh man well
I'll stay out here then so you can get
the good footage to make sure I close
the door I hit a bear trap I'm an idiot
I'm it's dead by daylight just right
yeah just like that I replaced those oh
man or maybe it didn't I'm dying I need
to get back and heat them to get some
health well but okay first aid well why
was that so wet why was that so wet I
don't know oh the door closing is kind
of a stirring whenever I know yeah when
you're not ready for it
yeah you stay safe in the van I'll be
back by morning
I'm watching you are you you'll let it
know if it comes out behind me right
yeah okay okay hey were you looking yeah
I saw that market footage I hope his
work with it oh oh oh God he hit oh
where he's running right towards the van
all right all right
God yeah he got me again that sack of
[ __ ] okay well he's hanging around now I
got not again loop I don't see him
help oh that's him help
oh geez he's in camp whoa that's weird
okay I'm okay uh we safe up here I think
so
to seeing you gonna hit those really
money oh okay it's one of the ways to
break the game kind of is to stand up
there because if you're up there just
dances around okay I'm gonna play spare
traps around the camp that's a good idea
I got a lot of them seems good well he
comes after us he's gonna regret it if
we have to punt anywhere we're gonna
regret it we got the back of the van
I'll probably be good enough for our
survival yeah trying it's not working
come out come out wherever you are cuz
we're ready for hunting rednecks with a
lot of guns get my moonshine yeah yeah
unsure about your moonshine I think that
as a hillbilly you wouldn't know you're
not a real hillbilly are you no I am NOT
you have caught me in my lie what what
are you some sort of fancy pants yes
that is I'm from fancy pants rhode
island wow I didn't know that was real
town but considering I'm just a dumb
hillbilly I believe you sorry I hit
control I didn't know control shot
don't mind me wet myself
I'll devolve it into a hill villa I
think I'll grind right there that's what
happened when you nearly get Xiao ya you
devolve into hillbilly cuz I think it's
really good for me to be up here with a
sniper rifle for he gets nice and close
yeah okay I'm watching man this cameras
shaky I'm gonna watch you get eaten I'm
gonna watch you
I'm gonna watch when it happens cuz so
janky see oh I thought you just went
completely horizontal babe
uh-oh you died hello a sniper oh come on
man we probably needed that maybe why
everybody homes I might forget a goddamn
[ __ ]
why are there so many big jobs around
the camp
I'm face-first into this one where are
you up on the hill oh the hill that has
all the bear traps to get up to a guy
hit it again
[ __ ] why is there an option to be the
rake I wish we could are you done - yeah
oh my god my corpse ready to face first
I'm not I'm so far oh there's oh did you
hit 100 did it hit one
it must have well we don't have a
shotgun or sniper rifle so we didn't
find the house that has the other gun we
have to beat it to death with our fists
oh here's another corpse well I moved
I'm no longer in the bear trap the rake
muster come by oh my god it's here yeah
whoa health up you just bring it in from
the sky others so many bow how many
corpses can we leave watch whatever if
we die watch the spawn like okay I'm
gonna stare at this point right here
alright ready we zoom in from who knows
where
oh there's so many corpses alright so I
guess we're down here we kind of broke
the game we got a giant pile of corpses
here umm of a certain people actually
it's weird they don't actually look like
us these these dead bodies there we're
wearing like yellow bit ah [ __ ] bear
trap hey we're all done here hope you
enjoyed this um we can't figure out
other ways to play this game because the
rake doesn't want to play nicely so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you wait for joining me on this
one I played her check out Wade's of
channel in the description below and as
always we will see you in the next video